Netflix is a vast sea of entertainment options.
So many, in fact, that you may feel like you're
drowning in possibilities.
We get it.
It can overwhelm even the most experienced
binge watcher.
But don't worry.
Because we're here to throw you a cinematic
lifeline with underappreciated gems on Netflix
that you just have to watch.
Moonrise Kingdom
Described as an "eccentric, pubescent love
story" by The Hollywood Reporter, Moonrise
Kingdom is definitely the most romantic movie
on director Wes Anderson's resumé.
This coming-of-age tale has a great cast,
including Tilda Swinton, Bruce Willis, Edward
Norton, and Bill Murray.
"I'll be out back.
I'm gonna find a tree to chop down."
And it also boasts a beautiful setting as
well as all the quirky hallmarks that Anderson
fans have come to love.
Nightcrawler
Suspenseful and visually stunning, this Oscar-nominated
thriller features Jake Gyllenhaal in a creepily
convincing performance as a sociopathic freelance
videographer tasked with covering the late-night
crime beat for local news stations.
"We find our viewers are more interested in
urban crime creeping into the suburbs.
What that means is a victim or victims preferably
well off and white."
The performance landed Gyllenhaal a Golden
Globe nomination for best Actor, while the
screenplay for Nightcrawler earned an Oscar
nomination for writer Dan Gilroy.
Tucker & Dale vs. Evil
The thing we love about Tucker & Dale vs.
Evil is how it turns traditional horror tropes
on their head.
This comedy horror film stars Alan Tudyk and
Tyler Labine as a pair of West Virginia hillbillies
who encounter a group of clueless college
students on a camping trip.
When one of the college students accidentally
hurts herself, the hillbillies take care of
her — until the misguided college kids attempt
to rescue her from what they assume are scary
backwoods hicks.
All sorts of hilarious and horrific hijinks
ensue, which make this movie a perfect choice
for your Netflix queue.
In Your Eyes
This Joss Whedon jam tells the story of two
very different people - a married socialite
from New Hampshire and an ex-con from New
Mexico - who have shared an inexplicable mental
connection since childhood that neither understands.
As the connection deepens, they realize they
aren't going crazy, because there actually
is another person inside their heads.
"I wake up, and you're not there.
I call all my friends."
But while they know they're sane, the rest
of the world isn't so sure.
The Way Back
Based on a memoir by a former Polish prisoner
of war, The Way Back tells the incredible
story of a group of P.O.W.s who escape from
a Siberian gulag and walk over 4,000 miles,
crossing deserts and even the Himalayas in
an epic quest to find freedom.
"This changes everything."
"There's nowhere to hide."
It also features amazing cinematography as
well as a stellar cast including Colin Farrell
and Oscar nominees Ed Harris and Saoirse Ronan.
Oldboy
While an American version of Oldboy directed
by Spike Lee was released in 2013, the original
South Korean movie is far superior — and
it's on Netflix for your viewing pleasure.
Based on a Japanese manga, Oldboy is a thrilling
neo-noir mystery, centered on the story of
a man who is abducted and held for 15 years
in a prison cell, with no knowledge of who
his captors are or why they are keeping him
there.
Then, he finds himself suddenly released and
given the chance to get revenge on his captors
— if he can find them in a mere five days.
And then… well, we can't say anything else
without spoiling the many shocks and surprises.
Kung Fury
Funded entirely by Kickstarter, Kung Fury
debuted at the Cannes film festival before
being released free of charge on YouTube,
where it gained such a cult following that
it secured international distribution on Netflix.
As crazy as that story is, though, it pales
in comparison to the utterly insane 80's action
parody mashup that unspools on your screen.
With everything from time-traveling demi-gods
to dinosaur cops to kung-fu Hitler, Kung Fury
delivers a knockout blow to your funny bone
that you may never recover from.
"Sorry I doubted you Triceracop.
You're the best damn partner I've ever had."
"I came back in time for you, Kung Fury.
Because, damnit I love you."
These Final Hours
With only 12 hours left before an asteroid-induced
global firestorm reaches Australia, a dude
named James abandons his pregnant girlfriend
in search of the ultimate apocalyptic party.
Along the way, though, the self-indulgent
and arrogant James meets a young girl and
discovers he has some serious choices to make
about how he truly wants to spend his last
moments on Earth.
"Forgive me then.
Forgive me, for what I'm gonna do."
Tense, edgy, and raw, These Final Hours shows
us the best and worst of humanity when pushed
to the brink.
Be prepared for an edge-of-your-seat ride
that will also inspire tears and deep thoughts
about what you would do if you only had 12
hours left to live.
Which is easy, just eat as much pizza as possible.
Centurion
At first glance, Centurion looks like another
vanilla sword-and-sandals war epic, which
is probably why it absolutely tanked at the
box office when it was released in 2010.
But it'd be a shame for any fan of bloody
action to pass on this hidden gem, because
Centurion definitely delivers much more than
it promises, focusing on a tiny band of Roman
soldiers trapped in enemy territory as they
try to make their way home.
"It's a trap!"
"Fall back!
Fall back!"
Michael Fassbender leads the cast through
every blood-soaked battle, while Neil Marshall,
who is best known for directing some of the
most popular episodes of Game of Thrones ever,
is behind the camera.
So sit back, relax, and watch a bunch of people
kill each other.
What else are you going to do while you wait
for the next season of Thrones?
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!